Hey guys,
I'm Nate. Welcome back once again to the dome, and as I hope you know when we're at the dome we do crazy fun stuff.
Today our experiment is to find out what happens if you drop a lit firecracker into gasoline.
Now, I'm not going to be quite so dumb as to just hold a firecracker
and drop it into a pot of gasoline at my feet.
I'm gonna set up a system so that I can light it, run away
and then have it drop when I am at a safe distance.
Firecrackers have a very short, very quick burning fuse on them. So to make this work
I'm first going to attach a little bit of a slower burning fuse to the quick fuse of the firecracker.
We'll then tie the slow-burning fuse onto a piece of string that's hanging from a stick over our pot.
Hopefully when it gets down to where the string is tied onto it
it will then drop still burning into our gasoline down below.
The idea is that the firecracker will light the surface of the gasoline as it falls in and then it will still explode while under the gasoline,
launching a giant fireball into the air. First, let's just test if lighting the fuse will make our firecracker drop down before it explodes.
I'm going to light the top of the fuse and then book it to the doorway of the dome so I'm safely out of range.
And as added protection, I've also put in some earplugs because it echoes a lot in here.
small_explosion.mp4
That actually worked really well.
I didn't...
...really think about how these slower burning fuses kind of had a lot of push to them and that sort of made it spin around.
But it still dropped fairly straight down, it still lit off and everything seemed good
I think at this point we need to try adding gasoline. I have a decent sized metal pot
and I'm going to start by just putting a little bit - less than half an inch at the bottom of our pot.
I'll light the fuse let it drop in and see what happens.
I'm not sure what the effect is going to be. It's possible that gasoline will stop the short fuse on the firecracker from lighting.
But we'll have to find out.
Well, the motion from the fuse swirling around made it miss our pot just barely
so I'm going to try and
change the angle of the stick so it's a little more right over it and it can't fly sideways quite as easily, try it again.
That's not how I thought that would go.
Huh.
Wow. That stopped the big fuse. It didn't burn through the string holding it up. It just came untied.
Now I'm just gonna light this on fire and see what happens.
small_explosion.mp4
I was a little bit surprised when our firecracker and fuse dropped into the gas and nothing lit on fire.
I thought the fuse would certainly keep burning and would probably ignite the surface of the gas.
That didn't happen so now, just as a test,
I'm going to try lighting a piece of fuse and throwing it right into our pot of gasoline.
Hmm. Not what I expected. It didn't light the gas on fire and the gas actually put it out.
Guess if there's too much gasoline
it loses the oxygen that it needs to burn. I kind of thought these fuses had enough oxygen
embedded into them that they could keep burning even if they are underwater, but it doesn't seem to work
too well with gas. I think what I'll try now is putting another firecracker into the pot with the gasoline
attached to the side so that most of the firecracker is submerged in the gasoline, but the fuse is above it and staying dry.
Let's try this out. I kind of have a suspicion I'm just gonna light the gasoline on fire
maybe then if firework explodes it'll just spread lit gasoline everywhere, which is kind of what we're going for. Here goes.
It lit the firecracker! Go, go, go.
Once again, the fuse went out.
I think it was sitting in the gasoline so long as we set up the cameras that it just sort of soaked up
so I'm going to try doing it one more time and just see if I can do it faster.
Try and do this quickly.
Whoa! Yeah!
That's what I was hoping for!
So it was already on fire, which I think worked to our advantage when it exploded. It just sent
flaming gasoline everywhere and kind of a fireball and that was a lot of fun. Well,
we want to try and scale this up. That was awesome.
I'm gonna add a little bit more gasoline
And then I'm gonna try and make it so several firecrackers go off. Not all the gasoline burned up
so I'm thinking we might get like one explosion after another of the gasoline which would be pretty sweet.
I now have five firecrackers attached this piece of tape. So same idea:
I'll lower it down so all five are somewhat submerged into the gasoline, tape it onto the side of the pot,
and then I'll just light the gasoline on fire. I'm not gonna try and aim for the fuses anymore and
hopefully we get five different explosions. That'd be neat.
Hmm.
Tape. An unexploded firecracker.
Hmm, several more unexploded firecrackers in the gasoline.
I think when the first firecracker went off, since it was
secured to the same piece of tape that the rest of them were, they all tore away from the edge of the pot and got
submerged in the gasoline. And I think we've seen that it only works if the firecracker isn't entirely soaked in the gas.
So I'm going to try it one more time getting five firecrackers,
but each one will have its own piece of tape holding it onto the side.
Here goes.
The fuse burnt. Firecracker did not.
Even all of the fuse burned on that one.
I think when the first one goes off
it might splash the gasoline so much that it soaks the other ones and it gets on the top of them, it gets down inside
and the wicks get hit and it just sort of stops working.
I'd say that's the one that exploded.
All right, continuing on the saga of good decisions made today, I'm gonna see if I can just light the gasoline on fire,
light the long fuse on this firecracker,
and then once it's getting pretty close to the quick fuse just toss it in and see if it happens to work like that.
I'm not really hopeful, but it's worth a try.
I
Ah, it went out. Alright, one more thing I want to try. I have three firecrackers which are all bundled around the same slow fuse.
I'll try taping this on so that they're only
partially submerged in the gasoline, light it on fire and see if we can get any sort of larger result with that. Here goes.
Fuse is lit!
I think multiple of them definitely went off. That sounded like a much louder bang.
There's like not much left in there.
There was a little burning bit that I think was the remnants, but I think at least two of them went off.
Maybe all three. I don't know if the fireball seems much bigger, but it's still pretty cool. One more thing
I want to try as sort of a finale
This is a good idea.
Fuse is lit!
Ah ha ha! Ha, it worked. I don't have a good way to put that out.
Well there you have it. An experiment to see what happens if we throw a firecracker
into some gasoline. We tried to set up where a lit firecracker would fall down into a pool of gasoline
and it wouldn't light. We tried lighting the fuse and just tossing it in and that wouldn't light either.
It seems that the fuses on these firecrackers just go out when they have too much gasoline on them.
We did get pretty good results by taking a firecracker with a longer fuse and just
attaching it to the wall of our pot that had a little bit of gasoline in it with some of the
firecrackers submerged in the gasoline.
And then of course we had a little bit of fun just by splashing some gasoline around our pot so that when it did explode,
it landed on the ground and lit all the ground around it on fire.
That's always a fun time, too. Of course for safety reasons,
I can't recommend you try this because it's very dangerous. Lots of things can light on fire.
Even here in this concrete dome,
there is a risk that the flaming gasoline could splash onto us even though we tried to stay a good distance away
while it was exploding.
It would be fun to try this experiment slightly scaled up with some larger explosives. That might be something we try in the future.
Thanks for joining us for this experiment today. Remember to come gear yourself up with products and merch at thekingofrandom.com.
See you there.
Once again to the- Wow, it's extra echo-y right here.
One of the firecrackers just went off. Did not see that coming.
Hey guys, I am on Twitter at twitter.com/thekingofrandom posting updates, behind-the-scenes, gifts
as well as responding to some of your comments and questions. Click the link the the description to come follow me on Twitter
and I'll see you there.